with formidable enemies elaborately
designed environments and heart-pounding
tension the evil within is an
unforgettable experience where every
encounter can end your life in the blink
of an eye
as a crimson city police detective
sebastian has seen more than his share
of Horrors but nothing could prepare him
for this surreal nightmare world that
exists in shifting planes of distorted
reality exploration has its rewards
extra ammunition and green gel er
sometimes stashed in dwellings just out
of sight in the midst of the unremitting
terrors ruvik the sadistic and enigmatic
figure stalk sebastian ruthlessly his
motives are unknown and his violent rage
is beyond anything human
who do you think you are I know who you
are there is a multitude of enemies
waiting for their chance to murder you
when you're overpowered and Outland
your only chance of survival is to use
stealth
throughout the game you'll find items
that can be used to help you remain
undetected use them either as
distractions or improvised weapons but
even with the most powerful weapons and
sound tactics there are battles that are
unwinnable
the truth to the mystery hides beyond
hordes of enemies in a series of
life-and-death obstacles deadly puzzles
are spread throughout the world in order
to progress you'll need to discover how
to bypass them when the environment is
as deadly as the enemies and you'll need
all your cunning to avoid the dangers
that lay around every corner
stalked by demons and haunted by death
the deeper you spiral into the mystery
the harder your journey will become in
the evil within death is the only easy
escape and survival will take everything
you've got what do you fear little one